wir wollen noch etwas in den usa bleiben
und zurück zu donald trump kehren denn
dieser zeigte sich nun etwas
einsichtiger hat versprochen es wird
eine geregelte machtübergabe an joe
biden geben auch wenn ich habe es gerade
schon gesagt er selber am 20 nicht dabei
sein wird er verurteilt das was am
mittwoch in washington passiert es sagt
seinen anhängern aber auch es ist erst
der beginn ihrer reise gehen bei der
heimische die in eidelstedt kerpen ich
möchte als erstes die abscheuliche
attacke auf das kapitol ansprechen die
alle amerikaner bin ich empört über die
gewalt die gesetzlosigkeit und das chaos
ich habe sofort die nationalgarde und
die bundespolizei eingesetzt um das
gebäude zu sichern und die eindringlinge
zu vertreiben die usa sind eine nation
mit gesetz und ordnung und werden es
immer bleiben r norden der devil die
demonstranten die das capitol
infiltriert haben haben den sitz der
amerikanischen demokratie beschmutzt an
die die an der gewalt und zerstörung
teilgenommen haben hier repräsentiert
nicht unser land und an sind die gesetze
gebrochen haben ihr werdet bezahlen
wir haben eine intensive wahl hinter uns
und die emotionen kochen hoch aber jetzt
müssen sich die temperaturen abkühlen
und die ruhe wieder hergestellt werden
die geschäfte amerikas müssen
weitergehen meine kampagne hat alle
legalen möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft um
die wahl ergebnisse anzufechten
mein einziges ziel war ist die
integrität der abstimmung zu sichern ich
habe so für die verteidigung der
amerikanischen demokratie gekämpft
ich glaube nach wie vor dass wir die
regeln unserer wahlen reformieren müssen
um die identität und die berechtigung
aller wähler zu überprüfen und den
glauben und das vertrauen in alle
künftige wahlen zu sichern
jetzt hat der kongress die ergebnisse
bestätigt am 20 januar wird eine neue
regierung eingeführt mein fokus liegt
deshalb ab sofort auf der sicherung
einer klassen geordneten und lautlosen
übergabe der macht dieser moment bedarf
heilung und versöhnung 2020 war eine
herausfordernde zeit für unser volk eine
bedrohliche pandemie hat
neben unserer bürger aus dem kopf
gestellt millionen iren zu hause
isoliert unsere wirtschaft beschädigt
und zahllose leben gekostet
um die pandemie zu besiegen und die
größte wirtschaft der welt wieder
aufzubauen müssen wir jetzt alle
zusammen arbeiten
das darf einer erneuten betonung von
zivilen werten wie patriotismus glaube
nächstenliebe gemeinschaft und familie
wir müssen das heilige land der liebe
und loyalität wiederbeleben das uns als
nationale familie verbindet an die
bürger unseres landes als neuer
präsident zu diesem was sie ihre meines
leben und an alle meine wunderbaren
unterstützer ich weiß ihr seid
enttäuscht aber ich möchte dass ihr
wisst was das erst der beginn einer
unglaublichen reise und danke gott segne
sie und gott segne die usa und wir
wollen über diesen richtungswechsel
diesen vermeintlichen sprechen mit
unserem man in washington mit herbert
bauernebel hallo herr barth sagt uns
einmal was steckt hinter diesen
richtungswechsel und ist er glaubwürdig
es scheint also möchte donald trump ihr
den kopf aus der schlinge ziehen man
muss auch dazu sagen wenn er als er
behauptet hat dass er die nationalgarde
aktiviert ist das eine weitere lüge es
war der vize präsident mike pence der
die nationalgarde aktiviert hat an
diesem wirklich furchtbaren tag für
amerika klar ist natürlich dass damals
zumindest den wahlniederlage erstmals
ein gesteht dass er eine machtübergabe
verspricht dass er auch erstmals die
stürmer des kapitols verurteilt und sagt
sie werden einen preis bezahlen
für diese für ihre aktionen für ihre
muss man ja fast sagen einheimischen
terrorismus der hier abgegangen ist es
eines ist klar die der druck auf 300 m
ist dramatisch gewachsen natürlich hat
auch die ganze story eine neue dimension
durch den tod des polizisten und jetzt
scheinen hier alle dämme zu brechen in
washington besonders die demokraten
machen enormen druck auf damals tramper
es ist jetzt die rede dass es bereits
eine anfang nächster woche erste artikel
geben kann über ein neues impeachment
verfahren das soll alles ganz schnell
gehen
die demokraten hoffen dass auch diesmal
die republikaner auf ihrer seite stehen
sie kalkulieren dass die republikaner
auch retten wollen was noch zu retten
ist nach dem desaster muss man ja fast
sagen so gesehen könnten die chancen auf
ein zweites impeachment doch besser
stehen als beim ersten mal alles muss
natürlich schnell gehen es bleiben noch
mehr 288 stunden übrig von der tram
präsidentschaft der zweite weg der
überlegt wird ist eine sofortige
absetzung von donald trump aufgrund des
25 verfassungsartikels wegen am zum
fähigkeit da hat vorerst vize präsident
mike pence blockiert er möchte dem
präsidenten dieser schmach ersparen aber
die demokraten hoffen dass sie
möglicherweise pence umstimmen können
dann ist auch die hälfte des kabinetts
nötig um diesen schritt zu unterstützen
klar ist donald trump steht am abgrund
nach diesen furchtbar nach dieser
furchtbaren woche in washington
herbert mehler hat es vorhin gesagt eine
theorie ist dass für die inauguration
von joe biden vielleicht stammt das land
verlassen könnte nach schulden nach
schottland fliehen könnte eine andere
ist dass er vielleicht nach florida geht
und dort gold spielt oder vielleicht
auch noch eine rally abhängt was ist
dein gefühl was könnte donald trump an
diesem zwanzigster januar am ende machen
diese zwei szenarien wurden diskutiert
in den letzten tagen allerdings vor dem
sturm auf das kapitol
besonders die das szenario dass donald
an praktisch hier am tag der angelobung
von joe biden in florida sich an seine
anhänger an seine trump bewegung wendet
um seine künftigen politischen pläne
hier zu schmieden und möglicherweise ein
neues antreten
für das jahr 2024 anzukündigen das alles
natürlich hat sich jetzt geändert und
donald trump ist klar geworden wie ernst
die lage für ihn ist besonders auch
aufgrund der tatsache dass das us
justizministerium nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen hat das auch gegen den
präsidenten wegen aufwiegelung oder
praktisch fast anstiftung zu gewalttaten
ermittelt werden könnte das heisst
donald trump hat angst möglicherweise
dass ihm sogar eine gefängnisstrafe
drohen könnte wenn es tatsächlich zu
strafrechtlichen anklagen kommen könnte
deshalb ist zu erwarten dass er
von all diesen plänen möglicherweise
abrücken wird und sich möglicherweise
wahrscheinlich eher still verhalten wird
eher still verhalten mal schauen ob er
das schafft herbertw in vielen dank für
diese einblicke und für dich alles gute
in washington
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren